what did it feel like getting the group
back together and first of all what does
it feel like to actually talk to someone
i i just to talk to you we haven't seen
each other in way too long years we went
through so much press together just
before the pandemic and got to see each
other so much which was always such a
pleasure
so this is amazing
this is as radical as when i got to see
this amazing uh group of people together
both my original cast all of us together
from the first jurassic park
and then this larger cast of jurassic
world
you know because of the global pandemic
we all lived together for five months
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i could use your expertise
you also told me you did some of the adr
in your closet yes
in fact we all did
my
i will remember well my daughter on zoom
in ninth grade across the house
coming in freaked out terrified because
i was screaming bloody murder
because i was running from a
giganotosaurus but in my closet in the
house in the house
oh my god and when she finally gets in
there she's like mom really mom you're
gonna scare the neighbors i'm like i'm
sorry i'm making a dinosaur movie in my
closet
you have lived most of your adult life
in this franchise what has that been
like and
people don't realize that yeah it's been
amazing you know i mean what's been
incredible as a young actor
having a lot of different worlds that i
got to be part of world of working with
david lynch and many other directors
this first experience of meeting and
finding the genius of steven spielberg
would turn into a lifelong conversation
of families and young children coming up
to me
young women in in science and history
and politics now saying what dr ellie
sattler meant to them as
as a badass character as a feminist um
so how it has lived and how this
character has lived for so many of us
has become in fact a big part of my
whole life you played a woman with a
doctorate a man with a tenured professor
at the tender age of 23. yes and people
are like what
and to see how she would evolve yes even
even in the world of science
you know for this final uh jurassic
world film
um was a really amazing and delicious
collaboration to have with colin
trevarro our co-writer and director and
steven spielberg and frank marshall
um
because
you know she was radical and she was
radical at a time that as you know very
well
we did not see female characters like
this in action movies no and it was a
big deal to see this woman who was
kicking ass but she was also a professor
and she was on equals with the other
people the men that were there yeah and
even when they were dealing with some
hardship or injury she was like don't
you worry yourself i got it i'll go get
the power back on and by the way she's
still like that now just so everybody
knows she is still like that still like
that you get back
you're reunited with sam how was that
amazing i mean sam neil is the dream
come true as an actor as a friend
to go through hard times with um he's
just an extraordinary gentleman
and the minute
i walked at that dig site into a tent
and there was dr alan grant
still waiting
for me to show up
i was i was very moved and it was really
special and then one of my favorite
memories of the whole experience was
the first day that sam neil and jeff
goldblum and i had a scene together
him with his ian malcolm with his
leather jacket and alan grant with his
hat we got into a jeep and as we got in
position we looked out and the crew was
surrounding the jeep and teary-eyed
because they were seeing these
characters that they had loved from the
first film kind of come back together
and i think this franchise has meant a
lot to people growing up and
i think colin really wanted to bring the
nostalgia of the first film back as well
i also think that people were waiting
for the romance between you and sam they
were so excited what was that was that
like the kiss
i mean
let's just see what happens
right don't give it away don't give it
away
but also it's this is a movie that's
helping bring people back to theaters
the comfort of theaters and what does
that mean and how important is that i
mean i know for me i was raised by
actors as you know
going to the movies has been
truly one of my great joys of my life
sharing with strangers
that you know collective experience of
storytelling is such a huge part of my
life
so for us a group of us who made the
movie only a couple weeks ago sitting
for the first time in a theater
watching the spectacle of this movie
in amazing right
screaming laughing cheering for each
other
cheering when we would do something
crazy laughing so hard at certain lines
i just felt so incredible you know
because we're fans and a lot of the
dinosaur sequences we hadn't seen just
like when we saw the first movie
so that was an amazing thing that we
hope
families and people who love this
franchise will really enjoy what was it
like integrating the new school crew
because there is a whole new generation
coming up now
amazing yeah how were they well first of
all as a woman
who with an amazing group of
collaborators as we talked about on the
first movie
we were really fighting for
something
new for a female character
to then see the franchise continue with
bryce dallas howard and now be joined
with the amazing dewanda wise
who is so great
and
live with she and her amazing husband
alano and
become family
who really like adopted my teenage
daughter who was there with us
was incredible and she's so amazing and
mamadou who's so amazing the film um the
amazing campbell scott i mean such great
new actors joining us
is this the end is this the end of the
line for your character
well
dinosaurs are always in all our hearts
and i would say it could never be the
end of the potential
of where this world could go
and
you know
seemingly it's um
there's a conclusion to many of the
stories that have been left unanswered
between jurassic park and jurassic world
but no one could have told me i was ever
going to play dr ellie sattler again
when we made this movie in 93. so i
ain't saying anything that's true right
you never know you never know where
ellie will end up because you're right
you're right yeah and i feel like also
she's a part of she's like a fixture for
certain things there there are people
who it does the movies feel weird
without you right
well i'm so happy she came back and she
came back to
really focus on preventing another
extinction that dinosaurs have a lot to
tell us about
and
hopefully the film really holds that
messaging
that we need to learn to peacefully
co-exist which we can take that on a lot
of levels where we need advancement and
compassion
hey before we go real quick what do your
kids think of this this branch because
they've grown up in this franchise what
do they think of it you know my daughter
had never seen it till right before we
started this movie
my son had seen it because he was a
little bit older because seeing
dinosaurs is scary but seeing them chase
your mother is like a whole nother thing
right so
so you have to pick the timing on that
but they're coming with me our world
premiere is here in los angeles and
they're coming with me and
so excited to get to see it
um
you know and the families of you know
our 400 crew members a lot of us had to
be away from our families to keep each
other safe so we really feel like it's a
community of our families helping us
sacrifice a lot to make this movie as
they were you know in
lockdown zoom school and all of that so
it's a shared experience that we're all
going to have together with our families
[Music]